hey you guys
merry christmas eve happy holidays
that's the day this is going up unless
you're a patron and then you'll see the
day before uh so i put a bunch of
christmas movies in the patreon poll and
this is the one that won and i was
interested the reason i put this in the
patreon poll even though it's not a
horror movie obviously
but
i think it's because i used to see it on
cable a lot like back in the eight late
80s and early 90s and i hadn't seen it
probably for at least 20 years so i was
really interested
to
kind of like see it in a modern context
because i know this this christmas movie
it turns up on a lot of
people's kind of like favorite christmas
movies but there's also kind of like
people that really really don't like it
and honestly it has like a it even had a
real mixed reception when it first came
out
uh and it had like a really troubled
production as well which i'll get into
in a little bit but this is the movie
scrooged from 1988. now you had never
seen this before
uh this is a richard donner movie yeah
uh which usually yeah it's well i i
don't think he was the first choice yeah
um i think actually sydney pollock was
the first choice they uh but because
when you think about it richard donner
he doesn't really do a lot of straight
up comedies uh he does action movies
that have comedy
to them i didn't know it was donner
we're watching it and i'm going man this
thing shot really well yeah it's you
know the edit is real modern i i'll give
it that other than that i couldn't stand
this movie
[Laughter]
you're not the only person i'm kind of
like
i'm kind of uh
not really one way or the other about it
there's stuff about it that i like and
there's stuff about it that's funny
but
some of the criticisms even uh you know
about the movie that came out at the
time i totally get that and i think that
um time has kind of like shown that up
so because we talk about this a lot
about
comedies and how
it's really hard for a comedy to sort of
stand the test of time yeah they
humor ages very poorly
yeah and i think this has aspects of
that because it does make like some
cultural references and things like that
which
maybe like wouldn't be funny nowadays
because people don't really know like
all this stuff about like mary lou
retton like playing tiny tim and stuff
like that which i thought was funny but
if you don't know who that is who that
is or how famous she was like at the
time like that probably wouldn't be
funny
you know what i'm saying so it's just
the material too that yeah it's not
funny yeah well here's okay so uh
obviously this is a loose adaptation
of a christmas carol which obviously has
been adapted 40 bajillion times roughly
and so i like that they wanted to do
like a more harder edged cynical version
of it
now apparently the two guys that wrote
it it was mitch glazer and michael
o'donoghue who were saturday night live
writers like back in the heyday
and they actually wanted to make it a
lot more
edgy and a lot more mean-spirited they
actually wanted it to be r-rated
um and i guess the studio which was
paramount they kind of wanted to tie it
more into like a family-friendly
ghostbusters-y kind of vibe because that
was bill murray's you know last big hit
so
so a lot of stuff that was maybe like a
lot more mean-spirited was cut out
uh so that they could get a pg-13
so the screenwriters
complained that they said probably only
about 40 of their original script like
made it into the thing and actually one
of the screenwriters i think it was uh
o'donoghue did not like the finished
movie at all um because he's like most
of our best [ __ ] was like not in there
now so uh the kind of context around
this so bill murray obviously had been
in ghostbusters in 1984
massive massive hit made him i mean he
was a huge star before that because of
saturday night live obviously but he was
a huge uh star
and
the fame that that brought him kind of
like freaked him out a little bit i
think um and he just couldn't really
handle it and
well yeah i mean
i never really got the bill murray i you
know what i love bill murray in the
right role i love ghostbusters it is
still easily one of my top five favorite
comedies of all time he's hilarious in
that it's it that was the material and
then yeah it'll kind of fit
and i think that and that was kind of
like the the interaction between him and
dan aykroyd and um and uh harold remus
as well
i think that's what really kind of like
made that because that's like a little
bit more of an ensemble whereas this one
he's more of a lead character yeah um
which kind of like so okay so he
invented that the the fame the fame kind
of like freaked him out and then he
since he was famous he wanted to do kind
of a more serious role so he very
famously starred in uh razor's edge
which is like a adaptation of a somerset
mom novel and uh it didn't do very well
um so and that kind of um disillusioned
him a little bit as well so he actually
took a break from acting for four or
five for three or four years uh because
he just wanted to spend time with his
family and get out of the limelight for
a little while now he was offered
scrooged i think in 86 at first and he's
like no i don't want to do it uh but
then later on he was kind of like you
know i kept getting all of these i
wanted to get back into acting i kept
getting sent all these scripts and they
were kind of shitty but then he's like
oh well scrooge that's that was like a
good script and he knew the
screenwriters because he worked with
them on snl and so uh you know so he
wanted to do it they gave him a lot of
money for this they gave him six million
dollars to kind of lure him back
and he was able to lure some kind of
bigger actors as well because there are
like a ton a ton of like celebrity
cameos in this
um you know gold dancers and the solid
gold dancers which like i said that this
i'll get it at a minute but this the
whole thing with the solid gold dancers
which again is maybe another cultural
reference that that people wouldn't know
what that was unless you grew up in the
80s um but that but that kind of had
like that was one of the funniest scenes
in the movie like the one thing with
them
but yeah so
so they bring bill murray back he hadn't
been acting in a long time he said look
i'm really nervous about being a lead uh
after i've been out of acting for so
long so he claimed he was like feeling a
little rusty
and also bill murray being a comedian
being on snl he is more of a improv guy
um richard donner was not really down
with that
uh and so and a lot of the other actors
weren't really down with that either not
not down with it but it was just like
hard for them to get around
um i think i read this interview with
carol kane
and uh karen allen who are also both in
the movie who kind of came for well at
least uh carrot allen came from more
theatrical background she had been in
indiana jones and temple doom obviously
she was also in starman
and uh she's like you know why i come
from a theater background where you
learn your lines and you know you can do
some variation on it but you're kind of
supposed to do it
consistent
um you know so he's like so she's like
it was a little bit weird having to act
with bill murray who would do like just
completely different [ __ ] and go like
entirely off script like all the time
because that was just his thing
but because they had hired him for so
much money they just kind of let him get
away with it and honestly they said so
much of this movie ended up on the
cutting room floor just because he was
he would do like these crazy [ __ ]
takes and he would do them like
completely different cocaine's a hell of
a drug every time i guess it's maybe it
was kind of like i don't really know if
he was known for being coded up or stuff
but i do kind of feel like a lot of them
do you did like do a lot of coke like
all these um all those sounds old
saturday night live cast [ __ ] from
[ __ ] co-kids
yeah i mean and you can definitely see
it i mean you can definitely see it
if you go back and watch like some stuff
from the 70s and 80s snl or any of those
kind of like comedy things it looks like
steve martin and you know robin williams
and stuff like that they're they're all
just very very manic they're very
high
lots and lots of cocaine jim belushi
yeah yeah so that's kind of like one
thing and it's funny because nowadays
bill murray i feel like he's more now
that he's sort of like reinvented
himself yeah as this kind of like laid
back hipster
kind of funny which which in a well a
lot of ways comes across as funnier but
see that's why but see when he was in
ghostbusters he had like a lot more
deadpan [ __ ] going on and that's like
funnier to me
i i have a problem with
comedians in general not just him but uh
comedians in general that do this kind
of like over-the-top like zany
because it just seems like so like
desperate to me like it comes off across
like it's funny you know what i mean
yeah it's all out of style and this um
this has some moments of that
um
to me the funniest parts of scrooged are
in the beginning when he's being a total
shitheal like when when he's in scrooge
mode um i gotta say though that last uh
bill murray movie that we did see the
one with the the zombie movie the one
that had uh what's his name the driver
yeah the dead don't die yeah dead don't
die jimmy's great in that yeah he was uh
bill murray is great in that so
he he's a lot better than he used to be
i think but he
his style of humor was popular at that
time
i didn't understand it at that time well
it made money and then yeah
it to me it always came off as desperate
or a mixture of desperate and snarky
and and not funny
i mean the snark and deadpan with bill
murray is funnier to me but see bill
murray
he said like in later interviews him and
richard donner did not really get along
uh and he said famously he's like i
don't think richard donner understands
comedy and interestingly he said i would
keep doing these takes and richard
donner kept saying louder louder louder
and he's like i started to think he was
deaf so it might have partially been
richard donner maybe
kind of like hype trying to hype him up
and making him seem like manic and crazy
and maybe bill murray not wanting to do
that right um so i so maybe some of that
is on and you know honestly like i said
i love bill murray and i love richard
donner
but
i don't know if they were like really
the right combo to work on this this
might have worked better with a
different director that was more
into comedy i think it would have worked
better if it wasn't so
manic and so over the top in parts the
more the movie's annoying i just thought
it was obnoxious
i could handle it for about 15 minutes
and then i started checking out i was
like
yeah and uh
it's just it starts to become
kind of laborious to watch it for me
you know yeah i get i definitely get
that i to me it seems like
because as i said i i remember seeing
this back in the day and like liking it
but not loving it not so much that you
know it was something that i would watch
every year like muppet christmas carol
which is still delightful but
um you know but it was just like i
remember there being funny parts in it
but it wasn't one that i would revisit a
lot so i was kind of curious to see it
again and i think that's why there is
like some really funny [ __ ] in this
particularly in the first half and i
really actually like some of the special
effects particularly the ghost of
christmas future which i think looks
really really cool um you know the
special effects actually still look
pretty good like for 1988 this did cost
32 million uh to make and it made money
but it didn't quite make its money back
um so it was i don't it wasn't really
considered a flop but it wasn't as
successful as paramount paramount was
counting on technically it's great
donner's doing it it looks good it looks
really it really does look good and it's
very good it's just it's the material
the material the delivery the cast is
just
no thanks
everything yeah i think some of it
doesn't work because it's too broad
because i don't generally like broad
humor i like more deadpan humor or more
subtle humor or more satirical humor
black comedy i do like the idea
of them updating the scrooge story and i
do like them making it mean spirited and
darker you know harder edged i kind of
wish they had gone farther in that
direction
and made this even darker even though
this does have some dark [ __ ] in it and
it does have some satirical stuff
particularly about you know tv and stuff
i mean some of the funniest [ __ ] in this
is um the the fake like tv like
christmas specials that they have like
promos for at the very beginning like
the thing with lee majors
with santa claus the night the reindeer
died yeah some of it was good i mean
that's like [ __ ] that's hilarious i'm
sorry that part and it's just like that
whole part with like lee majors like
talking to santa and say this being
you've been a very good boy this year
this is one santa that's going out the
front door it's like you know what i
mean so like that kind of [ __ ] was funny
um the the promo that bill murray's
character frank cross made for their
christmas carol special which had like
uh you know like international terrorism
acid rain
because he was trying to scare people
into like watching the [ __ ] see that
kind that [ __ ] was funny the first part
of it
where
he's just a complete and utter [ __ ]
is like way funnier
than
as it goes on and honestly one of my
favorite things about it so one of my
favorite things we were talking about
the solid gold dancers before so they're
having this
[ __ ] christmas carol adaptation and
it's 40 million dollars and it's live
like in the universe of the movie that's
kind of meta
so they're so they're doing that and
they have like all these start like
buddy hackett is playing episode scrooge
which again funnier to people that grew
up in the 70s and 80s i don't know if
people nowadays know who buddy hack it
is um but you know it was funny back
then
so they have all that and then they have
mary lou rhett and being tiny
little ice skater no she was a gymnast
she noticed not an ice skater yeah she
was she was a little little bitty thing
she looked like a child
yeah and she had short hair so she did
kind of look like a boy is what they
were saying that so it was funny
yeah and like i said to me that's
funnier to me because i grew up you know
and and that would have been funny if
they had done because it was kind of
like a little bit i don't know if i'd
call it tasteless necessarily like
making her tiny tim like she's cured and
she's doing all these flips and [ __ ]
like that's pretty funny to me but so
they had the solid gold dancers
in the middle of dickens or christmas
carol yeah and the whole scene
of your brow face yeah the whole scene
of like the the sensor lady like coming
over going you can see her nipples and
he's like i want to see her nipples
but this is a christmas carol and she's
like well charles dickens would have
wanted to see her nipples then
for all you children's that
wouldn't know who the solid gold dancers
are
on television they had this [ __ ] top
10
music hits [ __ ] show they just do
like the top 10 of what was on the radio
i can't believe we used to first of all
i can't believe that [ __ ] was on
television looking back on it i can't
believe we watched it
well yeah we didn't know any better
didn't know any better it was [ __ ]
terrible it was just doing the time they
would do five seconds of each song and
it wasn't casey cason doing the [ __ ]
was no he had a different that he was
getting his own different solids gold
was it right and really and while they
would do that 10 seconds of the song
they'd have these dancers kind of like
acting the [ __ ] song it was [ __ ]
ridiculous
but we watched it because the solid gold
dancers were first of all was on
television and you had to watch some
but the solid gold dancers were [ __ ]
hot they were
basically basically high-end strippers i
guess you know uh
on anavar probably anavar and primobolan
you know they they were we were coming
out of a time where
every so-called pretty girl was really a
skinny little cub [ __ ] you know i mean
slim as a board to some women that had
shape and they were muscular and they
could dance
so they were kind of the solid gold
dancers they were legendary
every teenage boy knew who they were
and uh but to have him in a christmas
movie was [ __ ] ridiculous that is
that it was funny yeah that whole
scene about the nipples was fine yeah if
you because
we were always trying to catch nip slips
and [ __ ] what they were gonna wear
that was very revealing you could you
could find the [ __ ] on youtube solid
gold for the episode of kasala gold it's
[ __ ] ridiculous i can't believe that
was on television but it was but see
even back in the 80s they knew it was
ridiculous so the fact of like putting
it in a christmas carol yeah is still
funny and what was funny not only was it
on television it got good ratings from
what i remember it was you know well we
didn't have a lot to choose from yeah
and it was like
the dancing version of [ __ ] jerry
springer you know it's like that it was
just low ball low brow
zero content [ __ ] television yeah
yeah and i mean but yeah that whole
scene in this movie is like was very
funny to me because i really liked his
delivery on it and like the two crew
guys going you can hardly see her
nipples and him going and those guys are
really looking
like that like that [ __ ] is funny
um but then it was also deadpan that
they were in this [ __ ] yeah and the
background [ __ ] dancing and right and
you're going wait that's the solid girl
dancing right
see that's what's funnier to me just
like just a dead pen little little
touches like
like stuff that's not even referred to
like for example
in frank cross's office uh you know bill
murray's character his last name is
cross right up on the wall like over
where his exercise bike is it has like a
dictionary definition of cross and it
says a thing you nail people to yeah and
no one mentions it and i'm like oh my
god that's funny but it's like it's not
brought up so i kind of like like i said
i kind of like subtler humor in a lot of
ways although some of the violence in
this like the censor lady getting the
[ __ ] kicked out of her like everything
falling on her and stuff i'll admit that
was funny um but i'm not usually into
like
three stooges type of you know
you know that kind of stuff although i
mean getting kicked in the balls is
usually funny like that kind of stuff
but i don't know it's in small doses it
just depends on who's telling this story
what the [ __ ] yeah
humor is hard to do
you know and this one
if you ask me
is a spectacular failure
it's just
bad
bad all around the tone of it is very
strange and i think i remembered that
even seeing it back in i don't think i
saw this in the theater i think i saw it
on cable so whenever it came out on
cable 89.90 whenever and i think i saw
it then and i remember like liking it
like some thinking some of it was funny
um or you know kind of sweet or whatever
but then like thinking some of it was
cool but of thinking the tone of it was
really weird
but like i said it did have good moments
like i really liked the solid gold thing
i really liked all the fake tv promos
yeah um i really liked uh actually i
really liked the relationship between
bill murray's character and karen
allen's character his her name's claire
and she's like the the girl that he left
behind like on his way to success that
actually did seem really kind of sweet
and genuine like especially when he's
with the ghost of christmas past and
goes back and sees like how he [ __ ] up
and everything uh because she's great in
it i mean i love karen allen anyway
she's great in it um i also have to give
a shout out i loved uh david johansen
aka buster poindexter as the ghost of
christmas past
as that like foul-mouthed like uh cab
driver type thing i really really liked
him in that now he was not the first
choice the first choice for that role
was sam kennison which would have been
really irritating yeah if you guys don't
remember who said he's dead now yeah but
but he just like screamed all the time
but that was kind of his whole act as
leaves least as far as i can remember
yeah
but he was supposed to be in that and he
was really mad when david johansen got
it because david johansen was friends
with bill murray but honestly i think
david johansen was way better in it he's
like because i always liked him actually
he seems like a really charismatic he's
being the new york dolls as well in case
you guys didn't know another interesting
fact about david johansen being in this
is that arthur kane who was also in the
new york dolls and had like a really sad
life uh look up his wikipedia page if
you have if you don't know about that
he was so
angry that david johansen
uh did the buster point extra thing and
was in this big movie and was famous and
arthur kane wasn't even though there
were all these other bands that were
ripping off the new york dolls
that uh arthur kane actually jumped out
of a second floor window attempting
suicide it didn't kill him he died later
but he was just so mad that he was just
like toiling away in broke-ass obscurity
while david johansen was getting was
still famous
um and so that's so i thought that was
kind of like [ __ ] up but yeah i really
do like david johansen in this as the
ghost of christmas past he's great i
actually like all the christmas past
stuff like where he's going back to
you know his parents house and one of
his older brothers plays his dad and
like comes home drunk and like gives him
five pounds of veal for christmas and
[ __ ] like like that shit's funny and
then like him go being at the christmas
party and that girl like photocopying
her butt and like giving everybody
pictures of her butt for christmas and
[ __ ] like that like that's funny i don't
really like and i normally love carol
kane
i don't really like her as the ghost of
christmas present in this one um i
didn't really like all the kind of
over-the-top because basically she just
shows up and just like beats the [ __ ]
out of bill murray uh you know she kicks
him in the balls and like pulls on his
lip and hits him with the toaster and
stuff and parts of that are funny but i
think it just like goes too far
um you know so that part didn't really
like work for me too much i do like uh
the christmas future thing though the
christmas future ghost in this one looks
really cool he's like this really tall
like kind of apparition with the hood
but then his face is like a tv
and so like the tv screen like kind of
goes all [ __ ] up and then like shows
stuff that's gonna happen in his future
so that sequence i really like because
it's kind of creepy like i like how the
christmas future guy like comes through
all the tvs and then this big skeleton
hand comes out and like they show bill
murray like at his cremation and like
only his brother and stuff are there
like i think bill murray's like three of
his actual brothers are in this one of
them plays his actual brother one plays
his dad and one plays like a friend of
his but uh yeah so like i said there's a
lot of cameos i think john forsyth was
in this as
the jacob marley type character he's
like a golfer and shows up with the
thing golf ball falling on the back of
his head and like rats coming out and
stuff so that's kind of cool so this
actually does have
cool [ __ ] in it
um
and i actually even though normally
um bobcat gold weight is annoying like
his 80s persona was annoying but i kind
of liked him in this one he kind of
played an executive that got fired on
christmas eve and then he comes back
later like at the end and with a shotgun
and he's like shooting at bill murray
which you know doesn't really play the
same nowadays as it did back in the 80s
but
uh that part was actually pretty funny
like i still find bob goldthwait's voice
the persona that he put on back then
kind of annoying but
i liked his character in this one now
and i actually kind of liked um alfre
woodard as well like as
bill murray's like assistant and her kid
is like the tiny tim equivalent but he's
not like he's mute because like his dad
got murdered which again is kind of dark
so i liked like a lot of the darker
aspects i think it would have been
better one if they'd have gone darker
and gone r-rated
um you know which they've done in
subsequent years like this isn't really
very edgy at all compared to something
like bad santa or you know the the dark
christmas movies they've made in the
years since then
i kind of feel like they should have
gone darker and they should have reigned
in
maybe not so much bill murray's uh
improvisation i don't think that was the
problem but i think maybe
richard donner was kind of pushing him
into this sort of like manic
uh you know over-the-top kind of thing
and i think maybe it goes over the line
to becoming like shrill yeah it's
annoying you know and and so i kind of
so it totally it's very very weird
uh because some of it works and some of
it doesn't because it's just too much
i'm not sure how i feel about like the
last very famous uh last scene where he
where bill murray like takes over the
whole thing and like improvises this big
long thing about finding the true
meaning of christmas and everything like
that and it almost seems like he's
having a nervous breakdown like on set
like he's just kind of going this crazy
thing and i was like i kind of like it
but then it's kind of like
i'm not sure if i buy it because he's so
good at being a [ __ ] at the
beginning
that it's hard for me to buy this
complete 180
in his
uh you know in his world view i guess so
it still kind of comes off as him being
sort of like crazy and
cynical and mean and stuff like that at
the end i don't know it just seems to me
that
you can see
a little bit that bill murray was not
having a good time making this movie you
know what i'm saying like some of that
really seems to come through in
particular scenes um
and i don't know and it's weird because
i was watching
i think like oliver harper did a
breakdown of this as well and he showed
kind of a thing with the siskel and
ebert uh review from the time that this
came out cisco liked it uh ebert hated
this movie yeah um and he
said pretty much that he's like this
movie just seems so he's like it seems
so angry like and not in a way he's like
i just felt like nobody was having a
good time like making this movie and
bill murray indeed did say later on that
making this movie was miserable because
like i said he didn't
you know he wasn't comfortable being uh
in the lead role uh because he hadn't
been acting for such a long time um he
didn't get along with richard donner you
know his acting style didn't really gel
with the other ones so you know they
they were kind of having a rough time
and honestly i kind of feel like this
was a movie that did okay at the time
that it came out but i feel like when it
was on cable
it kind of got like a more like
appreciative audience but again it seems
like one that
yes i've seen it turn up on a lot of
people's favorite christmas movie list
like especially like dark christmas
movies or anti-christmas movies if you
want to call them that but i've just
i've seen just as many people
uh that really don't like it and a lot
of people don't like it for the same
reasons that you didn't like it um
and the reasons i i don't dislike it but
i wish um
that certain things have been changed
about it it's it's a very uneven
movie for me uh parts of it are very
very funny and still make me laugh
um but parts of it i'm just like man
that's like you said it gets to a point
where it's just too much it's like
obnoxious yeah so
i don't know i'd be i'd be kind of
interested to see what the
what the fan consensus is on this my my
advice is
absolutely not absolutely don't even
bother with it that's
just it's just not
it's just not artistically viable and
it's not a pleasant experience it's just
[ __ ] you know
yeah it's just [ __ ] and it's not
funny humor and uh
no
nah yeah like i said it had moments
there was some stuff in it that's funny
it could have been good to me it's like
and this could have been you know a
great action movie but it wasn't yeah
this could have been a great comedy but
it wasn't yeah yeah there there is
potential there
but they missed it
so no
no
two thumbs down from me yeah i can see
what you're saying no it's just that
like i said i s there's still stuff in
there that i like but
overall i don't think that i would like
watch it again necessarily and and you
know
i don't want to harp so much on [ __ ]
uh bill murray you know um he came from
a generation of comics that i didn't
really think was that funny to begin
with um
boomers thought they were funny i didn't
think they were funny even as a kid i
was like yeah
the only one
uh the only guy kind of from that
generation that i thought was funny came
out after these guys because these dudes
all kind of faded when did other things
that was eddie murphy eddie murphy took
over snl once these guys all left
and uh connor single-handedly revived
saturday revived saturday night live for
a while and then he went out to go make
movies too
um but eddie murphy was
very naturalistic compared to the older
generation of comics they were just
cocaine inspired maniacs party mania and
the thing about it though is that
sometimes that could work like for
example steve martin
although
some of his
stand-up was funny and some of it not so
much
if he was given like the a good script
like a good movie like the jerk or the
man with two brains then it was better
then it was funny a lot better yeah then
he was funny yeah but i've also seen him
in movies where he was horribly horribly
unfunny yeah terrible so i think it like
depended on the movie and i think bill
murray even though i love him i mean
he's a national treasure
like i said ghostbusters easily one of
my favorite comedies of all time like no
contest uh and he was great in that and
he's great and stuff like nowadays but
if you give him like the wrong material
it's not i think like you said it's a
little coked up it comes across as a
little try hard i think robin williams
had that sometimes too
even though robin williams could also be
super super funny and he was also a good
dramatic actor you're talking about
their movies yeah really wasn't talking
about that i was talking about the way
they were on snl and yeah that's really
where
their
their comedy styles came from that's
what made them big and they were [ __ ]
not annoying they were just real
obnoxious
but you know a lot of a lot of the
united states was on cocaine at that
time so it was funny yeah it was
they were so they understood that's why
i laughed yeah it was it was drug humor
yeah and it doesn't translate very well
because half the people are not coked up
like these well it's just kind of like
you kind of have to be on marijuana for
for like cheech and chong
you knew what i was gonna say
the ultimate incarnation of these
[ __ ] uh came about later on with
this dude named chris farley who was a
[ __ ] annoying [ __ ] i mean yeah see
i never thought she was just sorry no
there was nothing funny about the dude
um
you can tell that he was really trying
to overcompensate for insecurities about
being fat
oh he spent most of his money on [ __ ]
hookers and blow and he died
uh he wasn't funny and every [ __ ]
jock whiteheaded jock boy in the world
wanted to be [ __ ] chris farley and
thought they were chris farley
i remember this no i remember those dark
times
[Laughter]
they had dudes who would talk like that
yeah oh i remember remember those
[ __ ] yep and so they're all
murray and [ __ ] martin and all those
guys are kind of to me they're just
other versions of chris farley then
literally
well i think chris farley is kind of
like the extreme extreme he was big
on his predecessors really because like
i said to me steve martin and bill
murray and stuff like that can be
[ __ ] hilarious again man with two
brains with steve martin one of my
favorite comedies of all time they're
funnier when they're restrained that's
because they're in movies yeah movies
they i thought they were funnier than
they were on saturday night live and
they were doing their stand-up i'd
understand it was [ __ ] annoying i
mean in general i like more subdued
right or like subdued horror subdued
comedy like where you're not because to
me if you're trying really hard like
that it just comes across as try hard
and try hard is not fun
martin is [ __ ] brilliant when he's
got the right material like he's seen
when he he could do a little shop of
horrors he was doing a musical he was
[ __ ] great in it yeah he was
fantastic he's giving him the right [ __ ]
he can act and he can sing and he could
sing even on saturday night live he was
just [ __ ] so coked up same thing with
robin williams robin williams was just
you just couldn't take him on [ __ ]
snl
more from work was even kind of worse
his mother you could tell he was just
snorting so many lines he was just real
annoying to me but he mellowed out he
came up with some of the best [ __ ]
like horror type thrillers like one hour
photo [ __ ] it was great yeah and
serious roles he was fantastic yeah
bicentennial man
society [ __ ] yeah you know he he was
very talented
um
unfortunately took his own life
um
but he
williams got good when he stopped coking
it up
you know yeah well didn't didn't make
you funny it made you annoying [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah i kind of feel like the
comedy to me i like comedy that comes
across as not trying to be comedy i
don't like tryhard i don't like
like you said that's why i never really
liked like jim carrey or anybody like
that and i like jim carrey in dramatic
roles uh he's actually good when he's
just acting like a normal person what
same with will ferrell i don't generally
he's just acting like a normal person
though that dude is not well no i know
but i'm just saying that he can do that
so he can act and will ferrell like when
he's acting like a normal person yeah i
don't mind him but when he's trying to
be funny not so much
and because to me like you said it comes
across as very try hard yeah and that is
not funny to me i tend to like stay like
stand-up comedians i tend to like
stand-up comedians that just tell
funny stories rather than telling jokes
that's why in the 80s in the early 80s
me and all my friends [ __ ] the advent
of [ __ ] eddie murphy you know some of
the [ __ ] that he was doing on snl and
the raw series of the raw
the video that came out when he was
doing the stand-up we loved it because
compared to everybody else he was real
natural and he was real cool he wasn't
and he would tell funny stories yeah he
just wasn't [ __ ] cooked to the gills
being annoying yeah he didn't seem like
he was just like constantly screaming
screaming or wild-eyed or anything he
was just a regular guy and he was funny
yeah telling and he was being honest
you could tell that those stories that
he was telling were based on something
that either he saw or something that
really happened to him or something he
thought of
like he goes into white face and becomes
this white dude this is on snl and and
tries to live as a white dude he's
noticing on the bus that when the black
people leave all of a sudden they bust
out champagne and all the white people
are partying and they're not charging
people for nah don't worry they're just
giving each other jewelry and [ __ ] you
know what i mean it was [ __ ]
hilarious man
because he
just always wanted to know what happened
when black people are not around you
know and it's just
it's true you can see it on yeah you
guys didn't know that
and all on around man we just get free
[ __ ]
we get on the [ __ ] subway for free
get on the buses for free don't even
have to pee your tabs at the
restaurants we get everything just yeah
if i can go into a jewelry store they
just give us a rolex
because i don't worry about it
dear have a car take two tape
[Laughter]
read paper should only when you all are
around
but no that was a murphy idea
it was [ __ ] hilarious i feel like
that's an extension of the joke about um
dudes being mystified about women always
going to the always
going to bathroom
oh is there like some kind of big party
and there's like male strippers yeah
what's happening in that bathroom right
like right
yeah so he called it man that was that
was great man and the other comics
weren't doing that they weren't that
insightful or that
curious about life it was just
cook inspired zaniness and i never liked
[ __ ] bill murray when he was in that
mode because he just came off as a
snarky [ __ ] that needed his ass
beat
and really that's what he comes with is
i'd [ __ ] punch that dude and it's
just he wasn't a pleasant experience now
later on when he had good material he
chilled out you know i mean he is a good
dude you know he's good dude i've seen
interviews with him he seems like a good
guy
um it's just that back in those days he
was an [ __ ] i just didn't although i
will i mean like i said i'm gonna go to
bat for ghostbusters because he was
[ __ ] hilarious well yeah he was
[ __ ] hilarious he was very restrained
in that yeah
he's way funnier way funner when he's
[ __ ] allowed to do it mellow and
[ __ ] you know he's a lot funnier than
he uh that that's a masterpiece of his
i'm not saying he's not talented he's
talented he's talented he just has the
right material right direction yeah and
in this when they kind of be kind of
sober you know [ __ ] keep your nose
out of the [ __ ] and in this and it might
have been like i said it might have been
a richard donner like kind of making him
go louder and broader um than he
normally would have
i don't think that works to his
advantage no although i don't think it's
just him i think that everybody else
some of the other stuff like i said i
normally love carol kane um but i didn't
really like
uh
that whole like thing with the ghost of
christmas present i think that was too
over the top um you know it was a good
idea it was just like too much and when
and that new murray movie where he was
you know playing in that damn zombie
movie he was brilliant in it he was
great i was happy to see him
he would he did a cameo in zombieland
too which was which was [ __ ]
hysterical yeah so
you know he's good
um but he's he's at his best now if you
ask me i'd like to see a whole movie
with him in it
yeah
did you ever see well you probably
didn't see lost in translation although
that's not really a comedy
really
um but he was actually really really
good in that um that came out a while
back though back in the early 2000s
mid-2000s i can't remember when that
came out but yeah he was great in that
but it wasn't
like i said he's a lot better when he's
not well just the same like i said like
robin williams right much better when
they're restrained i like more
restrained comedy because it doesn't
come across as it's a lot of fun it's
yeah because otherwise it feels like
some obnoxious jackal is just like
grabbing you by the lapels and being
like wow that's funny you know what i
mean and it's like i can't really handle
that because i'm like no not really well
if you have to try that hard it's not
funny like i said many times before
comedy goes in and out of style certain
types of comedy goes in and out and in
general comedy ages very poorly you can
go back and see some of the old comedy
classics in the past they're not funny
not anymore they were funny in the day
but some still are but it's it's playing
one is still funny yeah that's still
pretty funny um young frankenstein yeah
that yeah no thanks that is funny
yeah a lot of the i want to still want
to see i want to go back and see stir
crazy i haven't seen it forever but it's
probably still funny
i think blazing saddles is still fun
yeah probably still funny uh but [ __ ]
that is not funny mel brooks history of
the world is not funny anymore
um
eddie murphy raw it's not that it's not
funny anymore it's not as funny as it
was
but yeah it was new it was a lot edgier
a lot edgier back then it's just some
things don't age i will say son of a b
since we're talking about stuff that
ages and stuff something that was
mentioned in this movie just kind of
like is a throwaway gag
uh where the president of the network
that bill murray works for which is
called ibc uh he's played by robert
mitchum by the way another cameo
and he says
he comes in and he says we need to start
making programming for cats and dogs
because all of these scientists have
proven that they're starting to watch tv
now yeah that was funny actually well
yeah that was funny but i was like uh
also kind of uh
weirdly pressing it because they have
that now yeah uh they have youtube
channels
that your dogs and cats can watch i
think roku has a couple of actual tv
channels that have you know like birds
and [ __ ] on there that like the cats can
watch you and stuff like that so it's
like that's that scene happened during
the beginning part of the movie when
that when the movie was still tolerable
for me to watch yeah
another another 10 15 minutes later i
was i was just totally emotionally and
mentally checked out i liked everything
up until like i liked almost everything
up until like the ghost of christmas
present part like i like the ghost of
christmas past like i said david
johansen's really good in it um and i
liked all the all the tv promo jokes i
liked all that um
i didn't really like the middle part of
the movie
and then i liked kind of the a little
bit of the end part when the ghost of
christmas future comes because i liked
like the imagery like around that i
really liked the shots of him going into
the crematorium and the creepiness of
the
you know ghost of christmas future and
the funny [ __ ] with bobcat gold weight
trying to blow his head off that was in
the office and stuff that part was funny
um so this has moments it has parts in
it that i like but
overall yeah it's it's kind of like it's
it would be one that you'd watch like
the funny parts and then skip through a
bunch of it you know what i mean so it'd
be that kind of thing but like i said
i'm kind of interested to see like how
uh how our 13 o'clock audience feels
about it because like i said i feel like
this is a very divisive
christmas movie i uh tell you what i
enjoyed superman four far more than i
did
and i like superman
that's a pretty bold statement so
that puts it into perspective
i'd watch [ __ ] superman four three or
four times i would never uh no no not
this one yeah i don't know if i would
watch this again nah i don't know if i'd
watch this again i've seen it a few
times like i said but i hadn't seen it
for a while
this one's best forgotten
you think yeah yeah yeah like i said
it's got good bits but i'm not a huge
fan of it so i'm gonna say it but i'm
interested to see what everyone else uh
thinks about it so tell us what you
think about in the comments and have a
merry christmas we will talk to you guys
again later
bye